this was the year China's leader Xi
Jinping doubled down on his efforts to
eliminate a virus that most of the world
had learned to live with
Darkly at the Communist Party Congress
in October he promised not to waver in
the battle to eliminate covert 19.
[Applause]
a month later that policy was at
Breaking Point
people that had enough
some even called for she to stand down
but it was the diversity of the
protesters that may have alarmed the
president more
the depth and and breadth of
dissatisfaction with the government
which ran across many sectors so
students young people on the streets
householders uh workers in factories all
seem to be saying the same thing that
they were absolutely Fed Up of this
policy that it was counterproductive and
and that they blamed for government the
government though appeared to listen
just Days Later zero covered began to be
dismantled with Chinese scientists now
saying the virus wasn't that serious
after all there is definitely a backdown
from president XI if you look at it that
way but he's done it very carefully in
that he's given all the power to local
government so if something goes wrong
that the local government's fault not
his and if something goes right then the
credit is is his
six weeks earlier president xi's
leadership had been unquestioned as he
secured a third historic term as party
Chiefs
with no obvious successor it's a
position that in theory he could hold
for life
and while his leadership seemed secure
the protests along with his Relentless
anti-corruption Purge have made him many
enemies I think what it has done is
reveal the degree to which people are
not buying into the idea that Xi Jinping
is both wise and and deeply loved by the
people congratulations
like mainland China people in Hong Kong
don't get to choose their leader
John Lee was selected by a committee to
be the territory's next chief executive
in a contest in which he was the only
candidate
Lee was a former security Chief
authorizing the use of tear gas rubber
bullets and occasional live rounds to
disperse protesters during the 2019
unrest
in contrast there were local elections
once more in the nearby Democratic
island of Taiwan
but they didn't go the president's way
forcing xying when to resign as
chairwoman of the governing Party The
Victors the kmt traditionally favor
stronger economic ties with China
the mainland's economy though is no
longer the global engine for growth it
once was mainly because of President XI
zero covet strategy of particular
concern Rising youth unemployment we
have for example in China cities a youth
unemployment rate estimated around 18 to
20 percent
we have people coming out of
universities who are finding it
difficult to get jobs so that's Urban
middle class discontent
at the other end of the spectrum you
have migrant workers whose factories
were forced to close
it was a year when President xi's frail
predecessor hujin Tao was mysteriously
removed from the party Congress
speculation as to why continues
a month later another former president
Zhang zumin died age 96. his passing
bringing to mind a China that once
seemed more open and connected to the
world
Adrian Brown Al Jazeera